hello and welcome it is July 17th 2024
we're in active inference guest stream
83.1 with Josh bongard thank you for
joining this should be very exciting
we'll have a presentation and then some
discussion so if you're in the live chat
please feel free to write any questions
and thank you again Josh looking forward
to
this yeah thank you Daniel and thanks to
those of you that are attending online
um so my name is Josh bongard I'm a
professor of computer science uh here at
the University of Vermont and um my
bread and butter in my lab is the study
of Robotics and Ai and obviously we're
in the middle of the uh a current AI
summer um so what I wanted to do today
is uh show a couple highlights from my
group things that I've worked on in the
past and that we're working on at the
moment
um that I hope in the long term will
help us realize sort of the long-term
vision for a lot of those trying to
create intelligent machines which is to
create machines that are helpful but but
also safe um we're part of the way there
but as anyone who's worked with chat GPT
or stable diffusion NOS or even has a
robot vacuum cleaner at home there's
some limitations to our current
technology it's hard to create machines
that are
autonomous and useful and safe all
simultaneously so what are the things
that we're missing um that's what I
wanted to sort of um seed the pool with
today and hopefully we can move on to an
interactive discussion about it so uh
I'm going to leave this slide up and
just sort of talk over this slide for a
few minutes that'll hopefully generate
some food for thought and then
questions um this is a snapshot from uh
some of the projects I've worked on over
the years um first thing you'll probably
notice is there's a lot of different
robots that have very different
structural properties they not only act
differently but look very different and
that is a fundamental foundation in
everything we do uh in my research Group
which is to try and understand how the
body facilitates uh cognition uh years
ago with my PhD advisor we wrote a
popular science book called How the body
shapes the way we think and we can mean
that literally or figuratively um we
wrote that book a while ago we made some
arguments about how the body shapes the
way we think and since that time my
group and others have formulated uh
other uh Arguments for why or how the
body shapes the way we think and I'm
hoping to survey some of those uh today
so as I mentioned you can see a lot of
different robots here very different
structure they're they're they've got
very different Form and Function but
across each of the um pair of videos
that you see here you'll notice that
there's also a common pattern which is
on the left side you tend to see
something that's virtual and on the
right side of the video pair you tend to
see something that's physical and this
illustrates the basic approach that my
group takes to understanding how the
body shapes the way we think which is to
create AI that creates robots creates
embodied AI so what do I mean by that uh
what I mean is that in all of the
projects that you see here um we create
an AI that searches the space of all
possible
robots that could solve the tasks that
we want the robots to solve um most
people that are familiar with AI and
Robotics and autonomous cars and drones
have a rough understanding that AI is
somehow optimizing or tuning the brain
of the autonomous car or the Drone or
the the robot what have you there's an
underlying assumption in all of that
current in in most current robotics
which is that the AI Tunes the brain but
does not tune the body Tesla cars are
dreamed up mostly by humans and an AI
Tunes their their brain or their control
policy but of course nature doesn't work
that way nature produced us and all the
other intelligent organisms on this
planet by carefully tuning body and
brain
simultaneously certain bodies facilitate
certain kinds of behaviors and certain
kinds of intelligent behavior and other
bodies don't they obstruct that
particular Behavior or that intelligent
Behavior so in all of our work we ask
the AI not just to tune the brain of a
robot but its body
simultaneously and as you can see
visually here the AI often comes up with
uh bodies that are well suited to
whatever we want them to do so uh if you
direct your attention to the very top
left of the screen for a moment this is
now a 22-year-old experiment but I think
it's still visualizes the potential of
this
approach in this case we were interested
in uh creating a robot that can
brachiate that can swim swing across
beams or tree branches or electrical
wires for various inspection tasks and
you'll notice that in this case the AI
came up with a solution that in
retrospect seems intuitive um the robot
has to carry a very heavy battery which
you can see in the physical robot in the
top left there um the box that's at the
bottom and the AI has figured out how to
design the body of this robot so that it
passive it's actually able to exploit
the forward momentum of this heavy
object this battery to facilitate its
movement or brachiation across this
physical beam so it's a simple example a
simple robot a simple task but it
demonstrates uh this interplay between
AI robotics body and brain
if the AI was not free to place the body
uh to place the battery at a particular
place on the robot's body it would be
much harder it would require more energy
it would require a more complex brain
for the robot to figure out how to move
its heavy weight uh across this this be
so that idea of tuning body and brain
has suffused everything that we we work
on um some other examples you can see in
the top Center and the top right uh here
we have a robot um that uh suffers
damage its body changes over time so now
the AI has to Grapple with not just
designing a body but grappling with a
body that changes one of the things that
we as intelligent organisms here in the
world and all embodied AI all autonomous
cars all drones all robots have to deal
with is entropy the world throws a lot
of stuff at us we have to deal with wear
and tear injury in our case we grow from
a single cell into about 10 to the 12
cells we change massively in terms of
our physical
magnitude how do you continue to operate
keep yourself alive and do whatever it
is you need to do across massive
morphological change that is not an easy
thing to do and again it requires an AI
if it's going to do this with robots
it's got to figure out how to carefully
tune body and brain to
deal with the generation of behavior
inside a body that is changing either
unexpectedly due to injury and wear and
tear uh or
intentionally uh you can see in the very
center panel um this is again a pretty
good visualization of uh where designing
body along with brain comes in handy um
if we want to make flying machines or
swimming machines we have to very very
carefully tune the geometry and material
properties of the body itself to realize
flight um so what you're seeing in this
middle panel here this is partway
through the AI experimenting with the
design of different kinds of wings for
an ornithopter a drone that flies by
flapping its its
wings this uh flexible Wing that you see
here in the center of the screen this is
a bit of a transition from traditional
robots that are made of rigid structures
like you can see in the top row
into a more modern era in robotics which
is sometimes referred to as Soft
Robotics Material Science has come a
long way in the last 20 years so we can
now start to build robots embodied AI we
can start to build uh robots out of
materials other than rigid plastic and
metals um and we can again we can start
to move into an era in which robots like
organisms can exploit the material
properties of their bodies to facilitate
whatever behaviors they need to do to
survive or be useful to humans and so on
so in the middle right panel um this is
a highlight of some work that my group
has done in collaboration with Rebecca
Kramer Boo's Lab at Yale uh Rebecca's
lab uh is famously advancing the
state-of-the-art in Soft Robotics what
can you get robots to do when they're
made out of soft materials you can see
an example of some of those soft robots
middle right and a very different soft
robot lower left which is exploiting its
uh body properties in order to move in
interesting ways one of the interesting
things about Soft Robotics in my
perspective is that it starts to usher
in uh an era in which robots can
actually grow and complexify their
bodies you can see these Hollow cubes in
the middle right and these uh Hollow
sort of uh Chambers in the bottom left
expanding and Contracting as we push and
pull air into and then out of the body
of the
robot suddenly now you have robots that
can change their geometry they can
change their
volume they become what's known as
thermodynamically open it's a fancy term
for meaning that they can draw new
material and new energy into themselves
the thermodynamically open machines that
you see middle right and lower left the
only thing they're drawing into their
body is more air but it's a start I
mentioned already that humans grow from
a single cell into 10 to the 12 cells
every organism on this planet with a few
exceptions starts small and gets bigger
over its
lifetime that fundamental morphological
change
start small start simple and gradually
grow in size and
complexity that provides scaffolding it
provides a gradient on which to learn
how to gradually grapple with the world
around you most organisms again there
are exceptions are not thrust into this
world with all of their Machinery online
from the
beginning just the way I'm phrasing this
is obviously int to to sort of
dichotomize growing organisms and robots
with fixed
bodies autonomous cars are still very
dangerous autonomous drones are still
very dangerous to be around because
99.99% of the time they do the right
thing but every once in a while they
don't know what to do and no one knows
what they're going to do in those
uncertain
circumstances that that is a very
concerning situation as we start to now
deploy robots and autonomous vehicles
into everyday environments where they
are in close proximity to
humans why is it that in even with
state-of-the-art AI and with all of
Google's data centers and AI training
algorithms we still can't rub out that
0.01% where no one knows what's going to
happen part of the reason again is these
machines are born with complex bodies we
drop a controller into a one ton
autonomous car made of metal and and
plastics it's very dangerous we we don't
grow autonomous cars from a very small
simple lightweight machine that can't
cause anyone any harm whatsoever and
then when that simple small machine
demonstrates and verifies to us that
it's safe then we allow it to become
larger and more complex it sounds like
silly sci-fi why would we build a
machine like that but again every
organism starts simple and grows in
complexity and if it doesn't do the
right thing if it performs dangerous
actions that are harmful to itself or
fatal to Itself by definition it doesn't
get any
further that's again one of the ways of
thinking about how the body shapes the
way we think in my in my personal
professional opinion
any ma physical machines that we deploy
into the real world they should start as
very small lightweight machines that
can't harm anyone they have a very
limited number of actions that they can
perform and they sort of cycle through
all those actions and verify everything
and only then can they take more mass
more energy into themselves can they
recruit more material they can sort of
be allowed to be thermodynamically open
and grow and complexify themselves
there's lots of ways in which we we're
starting to create machines that grow
and complexify themselves I just talked
about these uh soft robots that can pull
in air or or pass possibly fluids they
could be hydrodynamic machines they
could mechanically or magnetically
connect to other robots that's Sort Of
Swarm robotics that's another path to
Growing
machines at the moment most of these
machines are still restricted to
academic labs they also are not safe yet
but I think in the long run they're
going to be a safer alternative to
dropping AI into very large complex
heavy dangerous machines and crossing
our fingers and hoping for the best okay
so I've talked a little bit about rigid
robots and soft robots um I want to try
and talk as little as possible so
there's some time for a good discussion
but I I want to talk about what I see as
sort of a third era of robot otics and
embodied AI which is just starting to
open up in the last few years which is
biotics or creating
biots and you can see two biobots uh on
display at the bottom center of my slide
here um a biobot is a robot that's made
up of only biological components no
technological components whatsoever so
in the bottom left here uh krigman
blackest and Len and myself in 2020
published a paper demonstrating the
first biobot um this became known after
publication in the popular media as
xenobots x n o Zeno
xenobots because these xenobots are
built from about 2,000 frog cells and
the cells were taken from a particular
species of frog which is xenopus leis uh
Michael Levan uh our biology colleague
at T University uh is world-renowned for
demonstrating that you can reconfigure
genetically unmodified materials like
for example frog
cells and that rearrangement of living
tissues not only does not kill the
organism the organism is able to in some
cases continue on doing what it does
what it needs to do uh ingest materials
survive reproduce in this reconfigured
state there's a lot of biological
implications for that one of the
biological implications is that frog DNA
does not code for frog what you're
looking at in the bottom left the
xenobot is about a millimeter in
diameter so it looks like a speck of
pepper to the UN to the unmagnified eye
and yet it's able to walk around the
bottom of a petri dish it's not quite
doesn't have all the features of a
living organism but it's got enough of
them that it's motile it's able to get
itself from point A to point B
so one of the one of the the other
implications for AI of this biological
discovery that you can rearrange
genetically unmodified living tissues is
that maybe we can task an AI with
discovering novel rearrangements of
living tissue to produce robots to
produce something that moves around and
does something useful on a human's
behalf so that that's what I mean by a
biobot biobot that's made from in this
case genetically unmodified
cells um the the swarm of xenobots that
you see in the bottom uh right uh as you
can see they're sort of pushing around
some material in their their dish this
um sort of visually hints at
applications for this this type of
robotic technology which is they might
be able to act like very very small
Roomba uh Robot vacuum cleaners in the
future they might be able to collect
microplastics out of waterways or cancer
cells out of
bloodstreams the the Swarm that you see
that's cleaning up uh in this slide at
the bottom right the material that
they're cleaning up is actually other
frog
cells it turns out that if the AI
designs this swarm just right and the
Swarm that you're looking at this is an
AI designed swarm the SW the AI came up
with the shape for each member of the
Swarm the Swarm is pushing these little
white circles these which are individual
frog cells pushing them into piles turns
out these frog individual frog skin
cells at a certain stage of development
are sticky and they Clump together into
a pile and some of these piles if
they're big enough if they contain
enough frog cells they will grow very
small hairs on the surface cells the
cells that are on the surface of the
pile
and those uh those little small hairs
are called cyia they're usually used to
pull uh dirt and pathogens off the skin
off the body of of frogs adult frogs
here when those cyia grow on small piles
of frog cells they're able to uh exert
enough Force against the surrounding
water that these piles start to move and
so what you have in essence is a child
xenobot this swarm wor pushes cells
together and in essence makes copies of
themselves this is another implication
of this work is that in this case the AI
has figured out how to design
robots that replicate they make copies
of themselves by by finding raw material
in their environment and constructing
copies of themselves this has been a
long-standing dream in robotics dating
back to um dating back a very long time
to John Von noyman in the 19 50s who had
a thought experiment it would be great
if we could create robots that would
create copies of themselves which would
create copies of themselves and if those
robots do useful work for humans as a
side effect for Von noyman that was
creating moon bases and then Mars bases
and then colonizing the Galaxy which
sounds great um but but the the seed of
this idea is if we want uh robots to
really be useful at scale instead of
manually constructing billions of robots
and then deploying them to do something
useful which is expensive would be much
cheaper to make one robot that does
something useful for us and by the way
it also makes two copies of itself which
does more useful work for us and four
and 8 and 16 and so on we're not there
yet with the xenobots but it's a
demonstration that that is possible and
again all of that becomes possible
because the AI is designing both both
the bodies and the brains of these
robots this is very far now from the
traditional view of AI and Robotics
where we build a robot body we humans
build a robot body and then the AI
Tinkers with the brain of that fixed
machine so part of the reason why I'm
here today and part of the message of my
group is we need to think more broadly
about how to combine Ai and Robotics and
possibly synthetic biology
and when we do when we think more
broadly there are Whole New Paths that
open up to ways in which we might create
in the future not yet but in the future
create intelligent useful and safe
machines in the current ERA in AI there
is one particular approach which is
autoc completion of tokens which has
come to dominate the field and and come
to dominate the popular imagination we
all kind of have an understanding more
or less of what chat GPT is doing and
there are some very strong lobbying
organizations out there that are bent on
convincing us that if we just do this
with more compute more data we will
eventually get to Safe machines my
contention is there just isn't enough
data out there to make non-embodied AI
like chat GPT and stable diffusion and
all the rest to make them safe we have
to think differently
about designing bodies and brains of
machines simultaneously to realize this
long-term
goal okay um I've been talking for a
while um I'm going to stop and I'm happy
to take questions or uh engage in some
discussion and I'm happy to come back to
any of these experiments and provide
more detail if that's
helpful over to you
Daniel thank you wow awesome what a
cornucopia of bodies and
Minds it was a great overview I was
really struck by some of the
similarities and the convergence on
whole of life cycle design and kind of
holistic Design coming from on one hand
a systems engineering and a materials
perspective and on the other hand from
the biology perspective with like Eco
evoo and this convergence upon needing
to think about how the endtoend function
maybe even past the point of
functionality like into the
planned graceful decay of a robot as
well so it it brings in a lot of topics
that even from an outsider's perspective
seem to be put as kind of secondary so
that's very cool okay great I'm looking
forward to what people in the live chat
write my first question is how over
these uh 22 years how have the materials
the theories like the contexts advances
and Turing computation all these kinds
of things how have they intersected and
just what has the ride been like as you
pursued these
questions yeah I think it's um the short
answer again is is is focusing on the
physical aspect of AI and Robotics so
the materials from which we can build
machines has changed over 20 years and
from from my perspective the the
experiment the top left there that was
something I did as part of my PhD you
know the materials at the time it was it
was very hard to build a robot you got
you bought some Motors you bought a
battery you bought some metal you bought
some wires and you wired everything up
there was there was the assumption that
bodies were fixed and not only that but
they were difficult to make so once you
made one you were very careful with it
to make sure it didn't change that it
didn't become damaged and that's seemed
to comport with a lot of the theory in
Ai and
Neuroscience which which had the same
sort of idea that that the brain or in
the case of Robotics the control policy
is the Puppeteer it's something that's
pulling the strings of a fixed thing
either the body of an organism or a
robot and if you look at a lot of a lot
of theory in both Fields Ai and
Neuroscience that that assumption runs
so deep so for example an active inter
inference or you know uh the free energy
principle we want to reduce surprisal
that there's a fixed set of actions that
we perform to try and reduce the
surprise between what we're sensing and
what we predicted we would sense given
the past action where do those actions
come from why are they fixed does the
set of actions grow over time maybe the
the sensory data that's coming is coming
from a new sensor that's just coming
online or a sensor that's recently
duplicated now there's two of them but
they're not quite reporting exactly the
same thing there there's a whole bunch
of assumptions underlying a lot of the
theory about active inference uh
predictive coding you name it you pick
your concept from Neuroscience or
cognitive science or
AI once you once you peel back those
assumptions imagine the robot's body
changes imagine the robot splits in two
and becomes two copies of itself you
know a lot of the the theory and the
formal the the formal underpinnings of
that theory break down you start to get
into ill-posed questions which force you
to now think about how do you
fundamentally change the theory if you
have a hierarchy of actions like in
predictive coding or active inference
what if that hierarchy is growing and
changing over itself is growing and
changing over time how do we address
that in a formal manner so to get back
to your question I think these advances
in what we can do physically we can
build robots now out of soft materials
we can build robots out of living
materials which on their own will grow
and divide and seek out energy and
material on their own that th those
physical machines these odd new kinds of
creatures are militating they're pushing
against the theory and specifically
they're pushing against these unspoken
assumptions that lie underneath a lot of
this theory about what's required to act
intelligently in a complex
world that's awesome like the real world
and the territory expanding into our
unknown unknown okay there's a bunch of
questions in the live chat so okay I'm
just going to go for them give any
answer that you like okay sure
David Williams wrote how do you think
about the controllers in your robotics
embedded AI at least today is rather
hard batteries and chips pcbs not soft
and not easily synthesized locally so
how do you think about the controllers
in your robotics yeah great question so
right exactly the controllers are
dealing with hard rigid fixed
components we need we need to start
thinking about controllers that can in
which for example the input layer and
the output layer can grow and Shrink
over time there may be new sensors or
new input coordinates that are growing
or being attached to a machine and the
controller needs to be able to carefully
deal with those new input channels while
the machine is
operating same thing goes for the output
Channel there may be new actions or New
Dimensions of action
along which the machine uh can act and
control policies reinforcement learning
uh all the rest of it does not all those
assumptions that make reinforcement
learning work which is what drives most
autonomous vehicles at the moment
assumes that the dimensionality of input
and the dimensionality of output the
things that the machine can do and sense
are fixed during training or during
Behavior generation during execution
that is absolutely not true in any
organism on the planet and that's
becoming increasingly untrue for for our
our coming machines now how to do it
well I I don't have any answers but we
have to figure it out that's you were
asking a question about thinking about
controllers that's a a concrete example
about how we have to rethink control
policy optimization even if we're not
thinking directly about the body even if
we just focus on the control policy
and ask what happens as the input and
output channel the dimensionalities of
the input and output channels change
during Behavior
execution yeah just one short point on
that it's like training with a fixed set
of perceptual elements or of affordances
or of actuators it's like training on
one point in a larger space of the
adjacent possible of like bodies or of
architectures so then okay we're
bringing all this compute to train a
special case in the fixed setting and
that's not even how the smallest
organism works so that just again like
kind of shows that point okay I ju sorry
before we move on from that point I just
to again illustrate how the body shapes
the way we think in the case of a
growing biological body there are new
input channels that come online you know
throughout our life time but they don't
appear denovo you know whatever it is
whatever that new input channel is as as
we're growing we just have more you know
more s sensory more sense cells the
signals that they're sending into the
peripheral and central nervous system
are not orthogonal to whatever else is
already coming in as input because new
input channels or new cells are slowly
dividing and at the moment of division
they're providing exactly the same
signal as some other sensory channel
that already exists so the body or in
this case biological growth provides an
immediate scaffold a gradient in in
robotics it's it can be very scary to
think about like attaching a sensor to
an autonomous vehicle what the hell does
it do with this new information that's
coming in because we haven't thought
carefully about how to add that new
sense modality to the machine again we
have to look to Nature that every new
sense sense modality is gradually coming
online and gradually drifts away or
becomes increasingly orthogonal to the
starting input modality so that's how we
should if we did that physically with
machines it would
simplify reinforcement learning or would
make it easier for reinforcement
learning or what have you sorry let me
re share my screen here it would simply
make it easier for
the uh sorry something seems to have
gone wrong here give me a
moment yep okay all right yeah it what
makes things easier on the control
policy optimization process if new sense
organs and new motor outputs are coming
online but they resemble things that
already
exist that's super interesting um brings
up a lot of questions about like self
and on self recognition and what is a
self as new and different senses and
actions come online sure um okay Pros
kavi
asks do these biobots have any sense of
agency what is your sense I'm quite
intrigued by the idea that Beyond a
critical point they start growing hair
and do these biobots act independently
of each other and also what happens at a
group level so what's your sense of
agency in bio Bots and I guess the
biobot and the group
level yeah it's a great question so I'll
start with a disclaimer I'm not a
biologist I'm a computer Scientist by
formal uh training so I I can only say
so much about what the cells are doing
and what they want to do um I I
definitely uh I I definitely follow in
the footsteps of the late Daniel Dennett
in that when we talk about agency we all
each of us individually has to decide
whether or not we take the intentional
stance or not it's in my opinion it's a
point of view if it's easier to explain
what the xenobots are
doing by talking about what the cells
want to do like grow cyia and coordinate
their actions fine if it's easier to
explain what the xenobots are doing by
not taking the intentional stance and
describing cells as mechanical
components that are transforming input
into out into actions that's fine too
it's uh this is something also that
comes from my colleague Mike Levan it
depends if as scientists if we want to
try and explain and understand what
these machines are doing if taking the
intentional stance makes explanation
easier fine if not then not but
attributing agency is sort of an
objective property of the Bots or the
cells themselves independent of us is
observers to me that's philosophically
and practically uh
problematic as far as I know there is no
objective measure of
agency in cells let alone inorganic
robots super interesting that's like the
second order cybernetics or the Observer
Theory or the poly Computing question
which is to say just looking at
something and then treating one's
perspective um objectively the case it
is objectively the subjective
experience absolutely now that being
said again there is there is an
empirical side to this we can make some
progress in understanding the
xenobots uh by comparing them against a
control so instead of cells if these
were you know magnets or some complex
mechanical system in which more of us
are comfortable in saying there is no
agency it's just a you know it's a
bucket of cogs doing
something and that control does not
exhibit kinematic self-replication for
example or it's much harder for the AI
to figure out how to put together non
agential
components to do what it is then then it
I feel a little bit more comfortable by
saying the cells are doing something
more now I don't know whether it's
agential or they want to do something or
if it's free will or Consciousness I
don't know but if but if we can point at
biobots or machines that are built from
biological components and say it's
easier to get them to do things because
they start to um they become complicit
in the overall goal compared to
Mechanical Parts which don't okay and
again as a roboticist in the in the top
the top and the middle rows that you see
on my slide here when we do build things
out of metal and rubber and Plastics and
Ceramics it's usually super hard it's
really hard to get them to do whatever
we want them to
do we've been working on robotics since
the end of the second world war and
we've got the Roomba and you know maybe
we've got autonomous cars we're getting
there it's taking a really long time
because robotics is really hard it's
really hard to convince physical
materials to to adapt and do something
useful and safe on the flip side we've
been working on Xeno Bots at the bottom
here we've been working on them for
about five or six years and we've got
roombas we we're making faster progress
in robotics when we build from cells
then when we build from metal suggests
you know the cells are somehow helping I
don't know that they want to help got to
be careful there that's the intentional
stance but when you deal with smart when
you when you try and compose machines
from Smart machines and cells are smart
machines we're making f i I know I'm
biased but I think we're making faster
progress than when we build machines out
of inert
materials yeah super interesting um okay
I'll read some comments from sure David
Clement David
wrote does your work incorporate
agential hierarchies for example the
xenobots grow by replicating the initial
seed cell into a higher order system and
is it critical for lower order systems
to act as a component of a virtual
machine meaning that they have a Target
behavior that is less than the higher
order system and that's kind of related
to to precautious question as well like
how do you bridge that from the
individual component into the Swarm or
the
aggregate yeah it's a really it's a
really good question so absolutely I
think the the when we started working on
the xenobots and Mike Mike Levens
started to talk about machines made of
machines made of machines that
definitely has influenced the work in my
group to focus on this issue of
hierarchy I don't know about agential
hierarchy again we just talked about
agential agency that's maybe a a
subjective stance but we but definitely
you know why would you want to build
machines out of machines out of machines
at the moment our state-of-the-art
robots like autonomous vehicles are not
hierarchical they the control policy
operates at the level of the uh of the
machine as a whole for example if
there's an emergency blowout of the tire
in an autonomous vehicle the tire itself
the rubber that makes up the tire
doesn't deform and try and fix or reduce
surprisal locally it can't it's rubber
it's inert material we don't we don't
have machines built of machines built of
machines yet but as biology in general
and the noots in particular demonstrate
there's an Adaptive advantage to being a
hierarchy of physical things of physical
machines if there is a surprising event
at the level of the machine as a whole
but that surprise trickles down through
the hierarchy it's unlikely that
everyone at every level of the hierarchy
is going to be surprised someone
somewhere in the hierarchy is going to
say from my local View at least on this
bigger surprising issue issue I know
what to do so let me start to
communicate to my peers and up the
hierarchy to deal with surprise that
would be from a engineering point of
view that would be a good thing to have
in you know big heavy fast-moving robots
that are near humans you there's always
going to be some surprising event that
the vehicle as a whole has never seen
before there's great YouTube videos of
you know horrifyingly
you know scary surprising edge cases for
autonomous vehicles okay we're never
going to fix every Edge case what we can
fix is to make hierarchies and maybe
agential hierarchies where local
surprise can be handled or or Global
surprise can be broken down into local
surprising events which can be handled
locally um if I understood the second
part of your question is how do we
design that hierarchy should the small
Parts be trying to pull in the same
direction or be trying to solve some
part the goal of the higher level I
think that's a super interesting
question and I don't think that the
answer is obvious it may be that smaller
parts pursuing orthogonal goals ends up
actually being useful uh may end up
being
useful just to give you a quick example
um if you want if there's a surprising
event and you've got a whole bunch of
semi-independent machines organized in a
hierarchy I would argue that every
single one of those members of the
hierarchy should have a slightly
different body and brain it should have
a slightly different Form and Function
you don't want a monoculture you don't
want all the parts being smaller
versions of the bigger parts and trying
to achieve smaller versions of the same
goals because then you've got you've
basically got a committee in which
everybody thinks and feels the same way
and as we know from humans that's a
dangerous thing right you get group
think or group act you actually want a
hetero culture you want a whole bunch of
things that are unique in terms of Form
and Function and that maximizes your
chances that someone somewhere in the
hierarchy says just because of the way
I'm built and the way I think with my
local control policy I know what's going
on and I have the seed of a solution
here's the seed you all figure out what
you need to do to make it a reality at
the larger level
that's another aspect of where the body
comes into
play yeah thank you like everywhere is
the last mile from somewhere things have
to be addressed locally no matter how
you think about a Communications
architecture
distally everything and embodiment calls
our attention back to that like it has
to be somewhere locally so then why not
take that as the starting point instead
of like this kind of resource Challenge
and then about like the multiple
subunits when there's a uh damage to the
nest of an ant colony or there's some
things spilled on the surface it's like
not that every single nestmate makes a
perfect Pebble move it's that 51%
accuracy with a bunch of
nonspecific flurrying of activity just
like kind of stress or these more
generic higher order in that is what
allows nestmates with different brains
and bodies to fulfill their own Paths of
least action and then colonies for which
that doesn't clean up the mess or it
cleans up too well and there's
externalities those colonies are swept
off the table and then we see the
Persistence of collective systems that
could figure that out in their growth
from a little colony to a big
Colony absolutely great great example um
i a question you you mentioned uh both
safety as well as like
reliability and how do you think
about capacities and evaluations on
diverse intelligences we're all familiar
with ram CPU hard drive storage some of
the Von noyman type architectural
descriptors however how do we even think
about what does that rubric or report
card even start to look like when we we
know that there's complex interactions
with the niche and when the kinds of
capacities that we're talking about may
have even
open-endedness yeah great great Point
great point right so you know we we are
the beneficiaries of you know two big
revolutions one of them is the AI
Revolution but then the older one is the
digital electronics Revolution right so
Digital Electronics works we all have
you know a supercomputer in our pocket
like there's no arguing with it it's an
incredibly powerful way to make machines
that internally communicate quickly and
richly and then can communicate with
other machines I mean that's it that's
that's the that's the information age
that we're in it's been so
successful that it's hard to think about
Alternatives or why we would even bother
thinking about
Alternatives but again living systems a
lot of what cells do they rely on
electrical
communication but they also rely on
mechanical communication chemical
communication uh thermal communication
cells are using all mod physical
modalities not all physical modalities
but as many as they can get their hands
on simultaneously all the time why why
don't they just abandon everything and
do everything purely electrically like
our modern civilization has done because
it's dangerous you don't have a
diversified
portfolio so uh one panel here that I
haven't talked about is the one in the
bottom right
which is basically just uh what you're
looking at is what's called a granular
material it's a material that's made up
of a bunch of grains in this case the
blue circles that you see these are
little just rubber rubber pucks and
there is an oscillation being supplied
at the left hand side and you can see
that this leads to interesting non uh
nonlinear vibrational Behavior within
this material what does that have to do
with robotics or AI
if you view the vibrations as the
carrier of information so if a if a puck
is vibrating that's a one if the puck is
not vibrating that's a
zero now you can start to imagine
creating materials that communicate
Shannon
information throughout the physical
structure not with electricity but with
a different uh a different modality
Dynamics or
vibration and it turns out that can
actually compose these metam materials
to embody logic gates if you vibrate one
particle or another particle but not
both and not neither you can see watch a
third particle and it will either
vibrate or not in accordance with an
exclusive ore gate and you can build
this up now again why would you do that
we can make an exor gate that's
vanishingly small and vanishingly fast
in digital electronics why would you
ever want to do something different
because it turns out there are
advantages of communicating with
vibration rather than electricity under
certain
conditions having a machine that can
communicate between distant parts of its
body through mechanical vibration as
well as electricity has an advantage
over a machine that can only communicate
long distances within its body
electrically I won't go into the reasons
but you can intuitively start to
understand that so again I think we need
to if we if we re if we're serious about
creating safe and useful autonomous
machines we have to break out of the
digital electronics assumption that
that's the only way to do things we have
to break out of the assumption that
non-embodied cognition is the way to go
and it's easy to just drop it into a
physical body and we're good to go we
have to peel back some of these very
deep assumptions about the right way to
do things that have built up in our
society since the second world War
because a lot of those technologies have
been very successful nothing wrong with
them but when we come to apply them to
creating safe and useful
machines not always the right thing or
the only way to approach
things that's really interesting it's
like a sort of generalized compute
concept where we could talk about well
these are the chemicals that it can
detect with this Fidelity and here's its
tactile interface here's its electrom
magnetic capacity for sending and
receiving that's what kind of motivates
or complement the generic Theory like
free energy principle which doesn't tell
us about how anything is in particular
but then sets us up with kind of the
framework to plug in these different
modules and then it's an empirical
question and then right here is sort of
the
um virtual body and a real body in
that's also very interesting H how how
does that work like in a collaboration
or with a graduate student like how do
you bounce this digital adjacent
possible off of the material and the
more costly um implementation with
embodiment yeah well with so with grad
students and postdocs or whoever you
know I'm collaborating with that's kind
of starting out you know this can be a
very frightening Prospect for someone
who's trying to get into Ai and Robotics
because it looks like everything's been
done it's solved like we all we got you
know we just have to wait for Google and
Microsoft to buy more compute and data
and they'll they're going to finish off
the last 1% of the dangerous Behavior so
if you're trying to contribute to
society's goal of making useful and
autonomous safe machines as starting out
what do you do it it looks like this
massive brick wall there's there's no
entry point so my take on this is again
is that we may be going about this all
wrong right the assumption that
electricity should be the carrier of
information inside an autonomous machine
that's an assumption why electricity why
not vibration why not something else so
even if you start to think about the
Alternatives the immediate reaction is
well it's it's not going to be as good
maybe maybe but if you think about
vibration you were just mentioning like
compute we can use vibration for compute
but vibration is movement so the minute
you start to think about vibration as
the carrier of Shannon information
you're now conflating action with
computation they cannot be
separated dayart convinced the West 400
years ago that they're separate they
just are and you you look at Ai and
Robotics what a surprise these you know
the our attempts to create you know AGI
is by Camal there's one team that says
it's going to happen in computers and
the other side that says it's going to
happen in physical machines that's the
cartisian Legacy that they're separate
but the minute you look at some very
humble material like the one in the
bottom right it's a bunch it's 12 hockey
pucks next to one another there's no
cartisian division anymore between body
and brain there there is a body and
there is a brain there but it looks very
different from anything we we would
usually consider and it's there's no
there's no value judgment here it's not
better or worse maybe it is depending on
what your metric is it's just very
different and so with grad students and
posts I encourage them to pursue that
what you know could we do things
completely differently and in the long
run might that be a better way to do
things what who knows we'll
see awesome I I'll make one comment and
then ask a last question you brought up
Dart and and that's the r extensa r
cognant uh dualism between the the the
the thinking and the non-thinking
substance and embodied cognition
embodied intelligence provides both a an
operational instrumental and an
ontological counterargument or comp
mentary perspective which is just well
in practice and in actuality take it or
leave it they are inseparable and so so
at the very least that that starts to
ratchet and LeapFrog the discussion
about what is mind and body and uh you
know you started with with pointing out
how important it was to co-evolve in the
complimentarity of mind and body and
it's like they're two separate things
that need to be complimentary and
tangling and also maybe they're
integrated and blurred in even deeper
ways than the dance so that's like it's
it's an empirical entry point into what
otherwise is a thought experiments which
can have utility but also can be just
arbitrarily misleading absolutely one of
my one of my former mentors Inman Harvey
at the University of Sussex used to talk
about robotics as philosophy with a
screwdriver you know it's not just
armchair philosophy it's when you start
to build some of these machines maybe in
retrospect you you in in the case of the
metam materials project for me in
retrospect I said oh my god there you
know mo action and cognition are not
complimentary separate things that are
complimentary they're one and the same
thing it's not embodied cognition it's
not an adjective of a noun it's
embodiment is cognition there they're
not there are no they're not there are
not two things here there's just one
thing very hard to think about it's so
alien to a western mind but you know it
just is sometimes I think about that in
terms of like adjectives getting added
in front of a word and then the term
expanding and then it it just
encompassing oh of course cognition is
ecological embodied inacted etc etc etc
etc and then so it kind of like needs to
be distinguished and then it subsumes
again and that's part of um in closing
like what are you excited about where
can people continue to learn more what
would you say to a person who's wanting
to like go in this
area yeah um okay great question
so Google my name and it'll take you
into lectures and papers and tutorials
and and people want folks want to email
me that's perfectly fine again Google my
name you can find my email happy to put
you in touch with the right people um I
think it's you know it's easier than
ever to get started you can go to chat
GPT and say you know create some
tutorials for me to start coding up
robots you know they're I ironically
non-embodied AI provides a good on-ramp
now not just for reading about these
ideas or listening to people talk about
these ideas you can start coding them up
in a way that was easier than ever
that's easier than ever the old days you
know you had to learn C and then you
know go on from there very easy to get
your hands dirty maybe not with physical
materials but you can create like you
see in the left of each of these panels
you can create machines that are virtual
they're not physical but they're
embodied it's another Point that's
important to make embodiment does not
imply
physicality you need to be able to push
against the world and observe how the
world pushes back but the world and you
may be virtual like you see on the left
or physical like you see on the right so
you can actually relatively quickly get
your hands dirty with playing around
with embodied AI uh these days and I
encourage everyone to do
so cool any last
comments I I would just say um I was at
the uh computer vision and pattern
recognition conference cvpr a few weeks
back this is one of the flagship AI
conferences 15,000 attendees and after
my talk a lot of grad students came up
and they said listen I you know you you
sort of demonstrated there's another
path here that I was feeling depressed
or anxious about how to make progress in
AI when these goliaths are you know have
these data centers at their beck and
call I would just uh encourage everyone
that when you think differently about
all this stuff there are New Paths that
open up they may not in the long run be
the right path but there are
alternatives to this monolithic predict
the next token idea which is currently
you know invogue it's it may be the
beginning of the end
um but I think this is just the end of
the beginning we've we've figured a few
things out there are some things that
work but they're still producing not
quite useful and definitely dangerous
machines there is room for improvement
and there's nothing that says that only
Google Google with all its resources is
going to be the one that can figure out
these improvements think differently try
some of these uh alternative approaches
and maybe you will be the one um you
know uh that comes up with the answer
whatever it is cool good luck awesome
thank you Josh really appreciate it
thanks for having me yeah and uh till
next
time thank you
bye e